what do you want from me what do you  want from me  what are you wondering why do you know  why are you scared i need big shows  big ideas i have a big one a faith  musical just click  hell away whoa you know calloway  no one's seen it for 15 years i won't  let you down sir better not or i'll  throw you off the roof  i've dreamt of performing in redshore  city since i was a little kid  he says that she's never afraid and here  she is  the star of our show rosita  oh my gosh  [Music]  it's been so long  it's okay  dream big dreams that's what i always  said right  [Music]  there's always a choice just never had  the guts  to make the right one  so where is callaway my sister is on her  way to meet him right now  okay  you